It has a long, thin tongue…
The wings of a bat …
And a taste for the bloody insides of sleeping
victims…so gross!!
It’s a self-segmenting vampiric female monster
with dangling intestines…This thing is insane!
Thank you PBS (DS) ! I’m finally making
a show about Manananggall !
[Monstrum intro.]
I’ve been dying to do this episode since
I first pitched this series..
There’s something so odd and obviously disturbing
about this particular monster.
The manananggal is one of many types of aswang,
a Filipino word meaning demon, ghoul, or witch.
These demonic creatures have appeared in literature
as early as 1582 in Spanish missionary texts.
But before the Spanish arrived, it’s very
likely that the indigenous peoples of the
Philippines already had oral folklore about
this monster.
The vicious, organ-sucking manananggal is
sort of like an aswang subspecies.
There are many different types of monsters
in the Philippines that are labeled as aswang,
but their appearance and habits divide them
into sub-categories.
There’s the blood-sucking vampire, the man-eating
weredog, the vindictive or evil-eye witch,
the carrion-eating ghoul, and the subject
of this video—the self-segmenting viscera
sucker.
The name manananggal comes from the Filipino
word meaning “to remove” or “to separate.”
This is what makes this aswang particularly
unique—because she detaches her upper body
from her lower torso.
She then soars across the skies at night with
bat-like wings.
But during the day, the manananggal is said
to look like a beautiful woman.
She is adept at successfully concealing her
monstrous form and maintaining normal relationships.
They can even be married.
Her true nature is revealed at night when
her arms convert to wings, her torso divides,
and she flies under the cover of darkness,
looking for human victims.
She’s known to use her long, thread-like,
tubular tongue to reach through an opening
in a window or roof, entering into the victim’s
body through the ears, nose, mouth, or abdomen
to feed on some pretty disgusting stuff...
Like the discarded phlegm from sick people—or
entire livers, lungs, intestines, and hearts
of adult victims, and even fetuses.
Pregnant women are rumored to be their ideal
prey.
Like I said, they’re really gross!
To prevent the monster from going back to
her normal human form, one can sprinkle ashes,
vinegar, spices, garlic, or salt onto her
lower body stump, which will prevent her from
becoming whole again.
So, to conceal her identity and seamlessly
return to that of a normal woman in the morning,
the manananggal hides the lower half of her
body while she hunts.
This is very important to her because she
will die if her upper torso cannot reattach
before daybreak.
Banana groves are reportedly good hiding spots.
Maybe because banana trunks can look like
human legs.
Their creation story is just as bizarre.
A woman is transformed into a manananggal
if she eats a baby black chicken that has
been produced from the throat of an older,
existing manananggal.
But there is one way to “cure” a newly
transformed manananggal —by removing the
baby chick from her stomach before it matures.
Supposedly this can be done by hanging the
woman upside down from a tree and beating
and fumigating her, or by swinging her violently
until she pukes up the bird…which to be
honest, also seems pretty horrifying.
If it’s too late for all that, and you need
to kill the manananggal but you can’t find
its lower torso to season, there’s always
a good old sharp bamboo spear in the back.
Some of the reasoning behind these attributes
is a mystery, but I do have a few guesses.
By naming pregnant women and unborn children
the ideal prey, unexpected complications of
pregnancy, even miscarriage, could be blamed
on a monster.
And the tubular tongue thing might have some
inspiration from the large mosquito population
in the Philippines, but those are only small
parts of all this weirdness.
We can speculate as to why this violent female
viscera-sucker became more prevalent after
Spanish colonization of the Philippines in
1521.
Before the Spanish influence, kinship and
inheritance were bilateral, with both male
and female familial lines recognized.
Divorce was socially acceptable and could
be initiated by either party.
Some women in ancient Filipino
cultures, also held important social roles,
serving as shaman priestesses, mediums, and
healers.
They had important duties and were involved
in many ceremonies and rituals, including
presiding over ancestral offerings of food
and drink.
As mediums, they could predict the future
by reading signs in nature and also interpret
dreams.
Considered the keepers of historical knowledge,
they would retell the myths that influenced
cultural morals.
Women also served as herbalists and midwives,
which are valuable roles in society.
But Spanish colonialism had a dramatic effect
on indigenous religious practices and the
roles of women and sexuality.
The pre-colonial Filipino cultures didn’t
put a particular value on chastity for any
gender, although extramarital relationships
were seen as improper only for women.
When the Spanish came and promoted (even enforced)
Christianity, non-marital sexual relationships
were increasingly discouraged, and procreation
was promoted as the primary purpose for sexuality.
Removing sexual, social, and religious power
from the female population in indigenous communities
changed how women were perceived.
The midwives, herbalists, and shamans were
recast as witches to discredit their influence.
Enter the manananggal . Think about it, it’s
a female monster who threatens to eat fetuses
among other things.
It’s literally an exact reversal of the
work associated with midwifery.
You could even argue that the reason these
creatures detach their upper bodies is to
separate them from their sexual organs.
Some scholars argue that the lingering effects
of the manananggal include architectural elements.
A fear of these monsters in rural areas may
have led to changes in how homes were constructed,
including the addition of steep pitches on
the roof and strategically placed windows
to discourage perching.
Social habits may have been affected too.
Children slept in the center of the room or
between parents to protect them from the long
tongue of the manananggal.
Another cultural practice could have been
influenced by a fear of this creature—how
balut is consumed.
Balut is the Filipino term for fertilized
duck egg that is boiled and eaten directly
from the shell.
No one is really sure how long balut has been
consumed in the Philippines because part of
Spanish conquest included burning the writings
of the indigenous people.
Nevertheless, there are some particular ways
of eating balut that might be explained by
the manananggal .
A 2002 study of balut eaters revealed that
although many of the respondents enjoyed eating
it, they were disgusted with the idea of eating
the embryo, especially if they saw the chick.
Could this be why the manananggal is the ultimate
taboo because it not only “eats” children
but the unborn?
Some said that eating balut quote “makes
a person like an aswang.
Also known as a manananggal .” Remember,
the manananggal , and other aswang, are said
to be driven away by salt and spices.
Balut is commonly eaten with pepper, vinegar
with chilis, salt, or other spices, perhaps
in order to unconsciously ward off the negativity
they associate with the monsters that prey
on the unborn.
I can’t help but think this connects back
to how these monsters are said to be created—by
swallowing a young bird.
Which came first?
The balut or the manananggal ?
Filipino horror movies featuring traditional
monsters contributed to a national identity
by revitalizing traditional folklore like
manananggals . She has been a staple in Filipino
cinema since pioneer filmmaker José Nepomuceno
made Ang Manananggal in 1927.
We’ll never know what this first manananggal
on film looked like since that movie did not
survive.
But she does appear alongside other aswang
in the 1932 film Ang Aswang and more recently
in a 2016 film.
A few of the female, self-segmenting viscera
suckers have appeared in Filipino popular
culture
but very few globally.
These monsters are relatively unknown outside
of Southeast Asia.
But that might be changing.
Netflix is reportedly developing an animated
series based on the Filipino comic Trese.
The award-winning series follows a female
detective who solves supernatural crimes.
There’s even a gang war between an aswang
clan and a manananggal clan.
The manananggal’s evolution is rooted in
the indigenous history of the Philippines.
It reveals how Spanish colonization forever
changed their culture.
She is one of the more physically unique monsters
I’ve come across.
I think we should be seeing more of this stomach-churning
creature.
Sooooo…. who wants to make a horror movie?